c'est un enfant qui vient voir son père
ça démarre bien enfants j'ai papa c'est
quoi la différence entre virtuel et réel
et le papa un peu là un peu c'est un peu
jean marie tu vois il dit écouteurs on
va faire une expérience tu vois tu veux
aller voir ta mère tu dis si haga lui
propose familiaux est-ce qu'elle y va
gamin il y va y revient il dit oui papa
maman elle a dit ça s'étudie et ben tu
vois virtuellement on est millionnaire
vous met réellement à une belle [ __ ] à
la maison est ce que tu veux moi je
voudrais dire un poème dans ce mic besco
oui oui c'est jean marie qui me l'a
racontée par raconte pascal jean marie
non non le nom laissant pas le sens pas
bien merci bonjour docteur oui qu'est ce
qui se passe mal j'arrête pas de péter
puis je suis petit je n'arrête pas de
péter mais à l'accouchement mais je
pétais tous à l'école j'étais à l'école
je partais en classe vettel à la
réalisation
j'ai toujours pdg incroyable ah bon et
après après le gel au service militaire
je paie et rh en brie jeu peut-elle pas
passée je me suis marié à la au mariage
à la mairie j'ai pas j'arrête docteur
jade docteur lagarde attendez je reviens
il par le médecin revient et une grosse
tige avec un crochet comme ça gagnent
quelque chose à faire vous allez mettre
dans le cul maintenant je vais l'ouvrir
les volets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez barack obama alors une propre
oui beaucoup oui oui on est prof c'est
le mec qui dit à la fille est ce que je
peux mettre de l'huile solaire dans ton
dos sur ton dos alors y mas i mas avec
l'huile solaire puis des sans idées sans
idée sans et la fille du dit attention
là c'est pas mon dos c'est plus mon dos
est notifiée mais c'est plus que les
salaires n'ont plus alors pas du tout
elle passe très bien
elle passe très bien je regardais son
mari le poète s'est beaucoup calmé le
jeu
une vague rigolotes sur ces deux joutes
ruche bavoil femelle qui soit tout d'un
coup à 50 mètres des voies deux jeux
truche mal est prennent peur ils courez
courez courez courez au fur et à mesure
et de mal se rapproche des deux femelles
et elle elle voit ça s'arrête net avant
un trou dans le sable cac est nette la
tête dedans quelques secondes à voile et
deux mâles arrive quoi coup de patin et
ce regard dit je vais elles sont où elle
est très belle attention et très belles
heures